hey this is pressed Hall Walker please
mind your decisions a bag contains only
red gold and green counters red gold and
green red gold and green Alice takes
that random a counter from the bag and
then she puts the counter back in the
bag Bob does the same he takes that
random a counter and then returns it to
the bag
the probability that both counters are
red or that both counters are gold is 5
over 16 the probability that the first
counter is red and the second counter is
not red is 1 over 4 charlie takes that
random a counter from the bag what is
the probability that Charlie takes a
gold counter this problem is adapted
from a GCSE exam this was a probability
problem that many students found to be
tricky and they didn't even know how to
start this problem if you'd like to
solve the problem pause the video right
now and when you're ready you can keep
watching the video to check your
solution or to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so ultimately this problem translates
into the following equations this is a
system of two equations in two variables
and I expect you would be able to solve
this you would solve for X and then you
would go and solve for y which is equal
to 1/4 and that's the probability of
drawing a gold counter but how do we get
to these equations let's start from the
beginning the story involves a lot of
details so let's break it up into parts
let's focus on these two sentences
notice that Alice takes a counter and
then puts it back in the bag and Bob
does the same thing these details
indicate we are sampling with
replacement the probability of drawing
each of the colors is the same on each
draw consequently let's focus on the
first sentence that the bag only has red
gold and green counters since we're
sampling with replacement we can specify
a probability for drawing each color
let's write X to be the probability of
drawing a red counter Y to be the
probability of drawing a gold counter
and Z to be the probability of drawing a
green counter now finally you actually
don't need this variable z because green
counters don't play a part in the
equations and in the ultimate solution
it's a little bit of a distraction now
let's focus on the next sentence the
probability that both counters are red
or that both counters are gold is 5 over
16 what's the probability that both
counters are red we need a red counter
on the first turn and then we need a red
counter on the second turn notice it's
the same probability because we're
sampling with replacement this becomes x
times x which is x squared we can do a
similar calculation for the probability
that both counters are gold we need a
gold counter on the first draw and then
the second draw this will be y times y
which is y squared
now we want the sum of these two events
to be 5 over 16 this is going to be x
squared plus y squared is equal to 5
over 16 let's then focus on the next
sentence what's the probability that the
first counter is red well that'll be X
we then need the probability that the
second counter is not red so we want to
multiply these two probabilities since
the probability of drawing a red counter
is X the probability of drawing a not
red counter will be 1 minus X we
multiply these two together and we have
x times the quantity 1 minus X now we
need this to be equal to 1 over 4 we
have a single equation in just one
variable X so let's expand this out and
then solve this quadratic equation we
get the solution that X is equal to 1
over 2 we can then take this solution
and then go back to our other equation
that x squared plus y squared is equal
to 5 over 16 and we can solve for y
which is the probability that charlie
takes a Gold counter substitute again X
is equal to 1/2 and then simplifying we
end up that Y is equal to plus or minus
1 over 4 since we're dealing with
probability we need y to be greater than
or equal to 0 therefore we get the
single solution that y is equal to 1
over 4 and that's the answer the
probability that charlie takes a gold
counter is 1/4 so it's a pretty tricky
problem but it becomes more manageable
when you break it down into steps thanks
for watching and for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]